Hey folks, my name is Nico. I work on
the AI SDK at Verscell. And in this
session today, we're going to be looking
at building agents with the AI SDK. Now,
this session is roughly divided into two
sections. We're going to start with a
fundamental section. This is going to
introduce you to the building blocks
that you need to understand about using
the AI SDK before we jump into building
agents. And then we're going to be
building a deep research clone uh in
Node.js. JS. So without further ado,
let's get right into it. To follow
along, the first thing that you're going
to have to do is clone the repository
here, install the dependencies, copy
over uh any environment variables, um
and then you'll be ready to go. In this
project, we have just one file,
index.ts. And you can run this file by
just running pmpp
rundev. I have this alias to just pd. So
if you see me typing that, that's just
running the script. Great. So let's
start with the first primitive that
we're going to be looking at, the
generate text function. Now, this is, as
it sounds, a way for you to call a
larger language model and generate some
text. So let's take a look. In this
session, rather than typing everything
out line by line, I'm going to be
copying over snippets so we can get
through things a little bit faster and
focus on the core concepts rather than
necessarily remembering to type
everything out properly. So, let's start
with the first
snippet. What we've got here is a single
function called main. It's asynchronous.
And inside this function, we call
generate text, which we import from the
AI SDK. We specify the model we want to
use. in this case, OpenAI's GPT40 mini.
Um, and then we pass in a prompt, hello
world. Finally, we log out the resulting
text that is generated and call the
function. So, we can head into the
terminal, run pmppm rundev, and we
should see a message back from GPT4
mini. Hello, how can I assist you today?
Now each of these generate text
functions and uh stream text and
generate object and stream object as
we'll see later uh can take in either a
prompt as input or messages and in this
case messages is just an array of
messages where a message has a role and
then some content. So this would be the
same as we had before if we change this
to user.
For the rest of this session, we'll be
using mostly the prompt key. So, one of
the core features of the AI SDK is its
unified interface. And what that means
is that we're able to switch between
language models by just changing one
single line of code. Now, there are many
reasons why you might want to do this.
It might be because a model is cheaper,
faster, um, better at your specific use
case. Um, and speaking of better, one
thing that we can try asking this model
in particular is uh something that we
know it might struggle with, like when
was the AI engineer summit in
2025. Now, I know for a fact that GPT40
Mini is not going to be able to do this
because it doesn't have access to the
web and its training data cutoff is
somewhere in 2024. So, we can see I'm
sorry, but I don't have information
about events scheduled for 2025,
including the AI engineer summit. So,
how could we solve this? Well, we could,
and we'll look into later, add a tool,
and that tool could call the web and
return those results and pipe those into
the context of the conversation, and
then the language model can deduce from
there. But we could also just pick a
model that has web search built in,
something like perplexity. So, how do we
change to a different model? Well, all
we have to do
is change the model that we specify here
to
perplexity, invoke that model provider
instance, and then select the model that
we want to use. So, in this case, we've
imported a new uh provider this time
from
AISDK/perplexity. Uh, and then we
specify we want to use sonar pro. So if
we run this again
now the model will come back. The AI
engineer summit in 2025 took place from
February 19th to February 22nd 2025 in
New York City. This is
right. One thing that's interesting here
is that unlike the OpenAI response
because Perplexity is using sources,
it's actually named them or referenced
them in its response. How do we access
them? Well, the AI SDK makes this
accessible with
the sources property. So, we can save,
run the script
again, and we'll see the sources in
line. Very, very, very cool. And this
isn't just limited to perplexity. We
support a ton of providers, and you can
check all of them out at our
documentation. If you head to a uh
SDK.forell.ai AI and head to our
providers page. You can see we have a
whole host of providers here. Um many of
which support web search as well. So if
for example you wanted to use let's
say Google's Gemini. So we can import
the Google provider here and use Gemini
flash uh 1.5 and then specify that we
want to use search
grounding. Save. Run the script again
and we'll see this same prompt with the
same configuration going off to a
different model at a different provider
and getting what we hope is a similar
accurate answer. AI engineer summit took
place from February 19th to 2025 and a
bunch of sources in line to confirm this
really really cool and really powerful
stuff. So that was the first primitive
that we looked at something as basic and
simple as just generating text from a
language model. But what if we want to
go beyond generating text and use
language models to interact with the
outside world and to perform actions?
This is where tools or function calling
comes in. While tools may seem
complicated, at the core, it's a very
simple idea. We give the model a prompt
and then we also pass as part of the
conversation context a list of tools
that it has available to it. Each of
these tools will be provided with the
name of the tool as well as a
description of what the tool does so the
model knows when to use it. And finally,
any data that it requires in order to
use those tools. Let's say the model
decides it needs to use one of the tools
to solve the user's query. Rather than
generating some text as a response, it
would generate a tool call. Meaning it
would generate the the name of the tool
it wants to use and any arguments or
data that it can parse from the context
of the conversation necessary to run
those tools. It's then on you, the
developer, to parse that tool call, run
that code, and then do with that as you
please. So, how do we do this with the
AI SDK? Well, let's check out a very
simple example. And when I say simple, I
mean simple. We're going to ask a
language model to add two numbers
together. So, copy in some code here.
We've got our same main function as
before. We're calling generate text
again. We're specifying our our model as
GPT40. Our prompt this time is what's 10
+ 5? Very difficult question, but this
time we are passing a tool. Now to pass
tools to the generate text or stream
text function, you pass a tools object.
Within that object, you specify a key or
the name of the tool. In this case, add
numbers. Then you can as the value use
this tool utility function which I'll
explain in a second to then uh define
what the tool should be. So the tool is
going to have a description. This is
what the tool does and this is really
important because this is what the
language model uses to decide whether it
should invoke that tool. Uh parameters,
this is the data necessary for the
language model to run this tool. And
this is what the language model is going
to have to parse from the conversation
context in order to use the tool. And
then you have the execute function. This
can be any arbitrary asynchronous
JavaScript code that will be run when
the language model generates a tool
call. And what this tool function does
here is this is completely unnecessary
but is a really nice DX um improvement
here. And what it does is that it
provides tape type safety between the
parameters that you define here and the
arguments that uh come into your execute
function. So to showcase this, if we
change this to string, if I can spell,
you can see I can't spell. Um, but we
can see that num one is still a number
where num two is a string. Uh, so again,
this is not necessary at all. Um, but it
does make building and uh, working with
these tools a lot easier. Now, what's
going on behind the scenes is that the
AI SDK is going to parse any tool calls
and then it's going to automatically
invoke the execute function and return
that in a tool results array as we can
see right here. And that's what we're
logging out to the console. So, if we
head to the console, clear it out, and
run the script, we should see a tool
result logged out to the console. And
that indeed we do. We see tool result uh
add numbers. We see the arguments that
are parsed from the conversation context
and then we see the result
itself. But notice that we have logged
out the tool results this time and
instead of instead of the the text
generated and and I had said before it's
kind of a nuanced thing here but the
language model isn't generating text
anymore. It's generating a tool call.
And we can see that if we said
console.log actually we just delete this
al together and we log out the resulting
text we won't see anything in the
console. It's completely empty. So how
can we get the model to actually
incorporate the tool results into a
generated text answer right? We want it
to synthesize this action whatever it's
performed and communicate that back to
the user.
We
could look at the last tool result. So
con's last tool result equals
result.tool results. And we pop we take
that last one. And then we say if last
tool
result equal uh dot dot name dot tool
name uh equals. And it's cool. We've got
full type safety here. Um, and then we
can say, oh, maybe we want to await and
and generate text further and return
that to the user. But as you can see,
this is errorprone. I've made like three
mistakes already. But also, it doesn't
scale, right? If we add 10, 15, 20, 100
tools in here. We don't want to write
out 100 of these conditional statements.
So, what we can do instead is use a
property called max
steps. And we're going to set this to a
number. Now max steps can seem again a
little bit confusing but what it is at
its core is that if the language model
decides to generate a tool call and
therefore there is a tool result we are
going to send that tool result alongside
the previous conversation context back
to the model and trigger another
generation and the model will continue
doing this until it either generates
just plain text i.e. there's no tool
result or we reach the threshold for the
maximum number of steps. So this is
quite a um a a simple but powerful way
to allow the model to keep running
autonomously picking the next step in
the process um without necessarily
having to add any logic or rerouting
repiping output here. So if we run this
code now and and what we're going to do
is we're actually going to log out the
result.steps.length and actually we
could even log out the
whole steps so we can see what's really
happening. And we're going to stringify
this so it looks nice. uh we should see
that the language model is going to
respond to
our if we go up all of the the crux uh
we can see 10 + 5 equals 15. So it
responded with plain text and now we can
see the different steps. We've got the
initial step which generated a tool call
add numbers 10 and five and then we can
see the the the tool result that we had
logged out to the console. A bunch of uh
stuff here. Uh cool note that you can
tap into literally the the raw request
and response body with the AIS SDK so
you can see exactly what's being sent to
language models if you ever need to
debug. But that's aside
um and then we should see the second
step. Uh and the second step was step
type tool result. Um and we can see that
there is text actually in this uh
generation. So cool. We've now seen how
we can build what we're going to call a
multi-step agent because that's what
this is. This this language model has
been given the ability to choose the
number of steps that it wants to use and
choose the the tools or the direction it
wants to go down. But obviously having
just one tool here doesn't show doesn't
showcase this very well. So why don't we
add another tool here to see this
agentic behavior in action. What we're
going to do is again I'm going to just
copy over some code. We are going to add
a tool that has the ability to get
weather description here kind of
obvious. Get the current weather at a
location. The parameters here we need
the latitude, longitude and city. Um and
then finally in the execute function
we're going to make a fetch request
passing in the latitude and longitude.
And then we are going to unwrap the
weather data and return it in the in the
tool result. Now a lot of people might
be uh thinking in their
head we're not providing the latitude
and we're not providing the longitude
like is this going to fail? And this
taps into a really cool uh inference
capability that we can use uh in these
parameters in that we can let the
language model infer these parameters
from the context of the conversation. So
we're fairly certain that the user is
going to give city as as part of their
prompt. And in this case we're going to
be asking for the weather in two cities
and then we're going to want to add them
together. So we'll know that we'll have
the city and we'll let the the language
model use its training data to
effectively infer what these might be.
Now I wouldn't suggest doing this
particular example in production but
there are a lot of really cool use cases
that you can use this pattern with. So I
foreshadowed a little bit our prompt
here is going to be get the weather in
San Francisco and New York and then add
them together. So we have two tools
available here. Get weather and add
numbers. And we have a maximum number of
steps of three. So we'd expect probably
well actually let's not even guess.
Let's see. We can
um print out the steps the length of the
steps uh the steps themselves and then
uh the resulting text generation. So I
save run the
script and we'll see a response. The
current temperature in San Francisco is
12.3° C. In New York, it's 15.2. When
you add these temperatures together, you
get 27.5 degrees CC. So, let's see how
many steps we had. Three steps. We had
an initial step, which was a tool call
step. Uh, we didn't unwrap this in the
in the in the console log, but I know
exactly what these are because I have
done this demo before. Uh, and this is
cool. We're using parallel tool calls
here. Um, so the actually we can see in
the body. We can see in the body right
here. Um, uh, or it's probably going to
be in the in the response actually,
which is also wrapped in in here, not
unwrapped. Uh, but what's happening here
is that we're doing our get weather our
our get weather call twice. We're doing
for New York and then San Francisco. And
then in our second step, we're going to
be doing our add two numbers together.
And then for our final step, we actually
uh have the the text generation itself.
Um and I can even if we do it again here
just to show you. Uh let's stringify
this out. Um just in case people don't
believe me, we'll do it one more time.
And this time we'll see exactly what is
what is coming out.
So if we jump, it's good good sign that
we're getting exactly the same response.
It means that the data is correct. Um
and if we scroll up to the where are we
the first
step? So three steps here. And yeah, you
can see so we've got two tool tool
calls. We've got get weather for uh the
latitude and longitude and the city of
San Francisco. The same for oops
scrolled too fast for New York. And then
we have the add to numbers
step. If we get
there, let's scroll
down. There we go. Add numbers. Number
one. Number two. We get our result. And
then finally, we have
our actual text generation which comes
at the very end. So awesome. That's two
major fundamental building blocks out of
the way. Generating text and using tool
calls. The final thing that we're going
to look at is generating structured
data, also known as structured outputs.
There are two ways to generate
structured outputs with the AI SDK. We
can one use generate text with its
experimental output option which we'll
look at first and two which we'll be
using more later in the session using
the generate object function which is a
function dedicated to structured
outputs. The generate object function I
will I will tell you is my favorite
function in the entire AI SDK. Absolute
workhorse of a function and we'll see it
later. So let's take a look at our
existing tool calling example where
we're getting the weather in two
locations and then finally getting the
sum of those two numbers added together
and see how we could add structured
outputs to make the eventual output
easier to use maybe later on in our
program. So the way that we're going to
introduce structured outputs here is
using the experimental I think we have
to head up here the experimental outputs
um output key. We can pull in
output.object from AI um and then we
define in here our
schema. We're going to be using ZOD to
define our schema. And if you've never
used Zod before, it's a TypeScript
validation library that is super
powerful and particularly paired with
the AI SDK seems like a match made in
heaven. We'll be looking at it a lot in
this session and it makes working with
structured outputs an absolute breeze.
So let's define what we want our output
to actually be. In this case, we know we
want the sum, which is going to be a
number. So let's define a key of sum and
make it a zumber. Finally, we add our
comma. And now, instead of logging out
all of this, all of the steps, and
instead of logging out the text, I'm
just going to log out the experimental
output. And let's run the script and see
what we
get. So, this time, instead of getting
all of that extra text, which we maybe
could have prompted away, we just have a
simple type-S safe object that we can
access. In this case, we've got
experimental output sum, which we know
is going to be a number, otherwise it
will throw an error. So, you can combine
tool calling with structured output to
build out some really, really awesome uh
use cases. Now, let's very quickly look
at the generate object function. So, I'm
going to delete everything in our main
function uh and copy over a generate
object example. So, we'll save, we'll
clear everything away. And in this case,
uh, we're going to be looking and seeing
if AI can help us with a very invogue
problem, and that is defining what an AI
agent is. I know Simon um had had posted
a a survey on Twitter asking for
definitions and had crowdsourced
something like 250 different
definitions, which ended up being six
categories of different definitions.
Anyway, nobody can can agree on it. And
so let's see if AI can help us. Uh
spoiler alert, I don't think it will.
But so what we've got here is our main
function as per usual. We're importing
generate object from the AI SDK. Uh we
specify our model as GPT4 mini. This
should start to look quite uh similar to
how we've been doing it previously. Pass
in a prompt. Please come up with 10
definitions for AI agents. And now with
generate object, we can define a schema.
In this case, our schema is going to
have one key. It's going to be an
object. That key is definitions. Every
um and this is defined as an array of
strings. And then that will give us a
type- safe resulting object that has our
definitions key on it, which is an array
of strings. So, if we run the script,
wait a second, we should see 10 probably
pretty bad definitions of what an AI
agent is. An AI agent is a software
entity that uses artificial intelligence
techniques to perform tasks autonomously
or
semiautonomously. Not as bad as I
thought, but why don't we see if we can
alter this slightly? And and the way I
want to do this is provide some more
details to the language model of exactly
what I want it to do for each of the
strings in this array. Now, we could
jump into the prompt and say each of
these definitions should be X. But one
of the really, really cool features we
can tap into with ZOD is the dotescribe
function. And with dotescribe, we can,
as it sounds, go to any key or any
value, sorry, and we can chain on
this.escribe function. And in here, we
can describe exactly what we want for
that exact value. So, I'm going to say
something uh kind of cheeky and I'm
going to say
um I'm just going to paste this in. I
want the language model to use as much
jargon as possible. It should be
completely incoherent. So, let's see
what this can do. Spoiler alert, this is
how I spend a lot of my time hacking on
on language model stuff, just like
asking really ridiculous stuff. And so,
let's see what we got here. autonomous
entities that leverage algorithmic
huristics to optimize decision-making
processes in dynamic
environments. That is complete BS. Um,
and we've got 10 of them. So, um, so
this is a really cool thing about
working with uh structured outputs with
the AI SDK and particularly with that
SOD integration. It makes defining these
schemas and providing context super
simple and really easy to maintain as
well. Great. And with that, we've gone
through the fundamentals of building
agents with the AI SDK. Now, we're going
to move on to a more practical project.
We're going to be trying to build a deep
research clone. Now, obviously, this
isn't going to be a full crazy
application implementation. We're just
going to be doing it in node. So, we're
going to have a terminal script that
we're going to build. We're going to
pass a query, and then we're going to
conduct a bunch of deep research and
write a a markdown report into our file
system. But in doing this, this should
introduce us to a few things. It should
introduce us to one, how we would break
down this idea of of deep research into
like a structured workflow. Um, and
within this workflow, uh, we're going to
have some autonomous agentic elements.
So, we'll see what a production AI
system might look like. Um, and we'll
also look at how we can combine
different AI SDK functions together to
build these more complex AI systems that
can really cater to interesting and
honestly cool use cases that you can use
in production to help build cool stuff.
I don't know how how better to to to say
it than that. So without further ado,
I'm going to head to the deep research
section of the companion site because
I've provided a nice explanation of how
the workflow is going to work in in
natural language and also a nice diagram
to explain exactly what's going to be
happening. Now also if you haven't used
deep research before one, I highly
suggest you check it out. Um, OpenAI has
a version, Deep Research, uh, Gemini has
a version as well. But roughly speaking,
what's happening is you give these
products a topic to think about and it
will go off for an extended period of
time searching the web, aggregating
resources, going down like webs of
thought and then it will aggregate all
of that information together and finally
return it into a report to hopefully
solve your query. And the cool thing is
this really taps into a fundamental a
fundamentally strong part of of language
models of this like
synthesizing troves and troves of of
information. Um so yeah let's look at
how this workflow is going to look like.
So the rough steps are going to be we're
going to take an input a rough query a
prompt. We're then going to for that
prompt generate a bunch of subqueries.
So let's think about like we want to do
research on electric cars. Uh the
queries or the search queries that we
might generate are like what is an
electric car? Who are the biggest
electric car producers and so on. Then
for each of those queries, we're going
to search the web for relevant result.
And then we're going to analyze that
result for learnings and follow-up
questions. And then if we want to go
into more depth, which we'll look at in
a second, how that works, uh we will
take those follow-up questions as well
as like the existing research, generate
a new query and like completely
recursively complete that process.
Meaning like we basically start again
while keeping all of the accumulated
research. And in this way we can go down
these like these webs of of thought and
of questions and and and build a
comprehensive
aggregated a comprehensive set of
information about a a given topic. So
what this might look like in theory I
like this little explanation. Uh so
let's say we have electric cars. We're
calling this level zero just like this
is the initial query. And at level one
uh we're going to have a breadth. Now
breadth is just like how many different
uh queries do we want at each step. So
let's say we're at we're at level one um
and we're doing electric cars and the
three search queries that we generate
are Tesla Model 3 specification electric
car charging infrastructure and electric
vehicle battery technology. And then for
each of those different queries, we'd
complete the research and maybe for
Tesla Model 3, we would then start
generating uh go down the web have two
breadth. Uh like we want to generate two
different u lines of inquiry to go down
and then we go down. Okay, we want to
know Model 3 range capacity and model 3
pricing. And then for electric char car
charging infrastructure, we want to know
fast charging stations in the US and
home charging installation and so on.
And so depending on what depth and
breadth settings we set um we're able
to control the level of information um
and the depth of information that we
gather. So that was a lot. Let's uh
let's jump into actually trying to build
this. And the first thing that we're
going to look at is building a function
that can generate some search queries.
So I'm going to dive back into
the back into the code editor. We're
going to clear out this file and we are
going to copy in our first function. So
the first thing like we said we want to
generate a bunch of search queries. This
is going to be a single function called
generate search queries. I'm very
creative. Uh it's going to take in a
query uh which is of type string and the
number of search queries that we
actually want to generate. We're going
to set this to be three just as default.
This is for you to play around with
later if you'd like. Um then we use the
generate object function. We're
specifying a main model so that we can
just uh set it once, reference it
everywhere, and if we want to update it
later, we can in just one place. So
that's why we're doing that. We have a
prompt here. uh we we use template
strings all over the place in this and
you'll probably end up using them a ton.
Super helpful uh for this use case. So
we say generate n number of search
queries for the following query passing
in the the search query and then we ask
for a structured output which should
have a uh an array of strings minimum of
one maximum of five although we're
setting it kind of loosely here at uh
three and then we return those queries.
So that's our generate search queries
function. If we go back to our companion
site, we see the next thing that we have
to do is map through each of those
queries and search the web for relevant
results. Analyze the result for learning
and follow-up questions and then follow
up with new queries. So, let's go one at
a time. The first thing actually we
we'll want to do is have a main function
so that we can actually uh specify a
prompt and then call this generate
search queries. So our prompt is going
to be if you were at the AI engineer
summit there's an awesome talk and
actually it's I think it's available
online from the Gemini team where they
walked through uh how they went about
building deep research. It was a really
really good talk and one of my favorite
things from it was hearing the the
prompt that they used as like the the
kind of the gold standard to evaluate
the progress of the the product and that
was what do you need to be a D1 shot put
athlete. So in that similar vein, we're
going to be using that
today. So we take that prompt and then
we pass it into our generate search
queries function. Uh because we
specified a default number of search
queries as three, we we don't need to
specify one here. Uh and then that's
going to return our queries. So we can
do just a little checkin to see what's
happening here and log out our queries.
run the script and we should see fairly
quickly we've got three potential search
queries for our prompt of what do you
need to be a D1 shotput athlete. These
are obviously geared for a search
engine. So like requirements to become a
D1 shotput athlete, training regiment
for D1 shotput athlete, qualifications
for NCAA division one shot put. So three
pretty good queries that I think would
make sense to to look for if you wanted
to learn more about this. All right,
back to our companion site. We'll see
the next thing that we need to do, map
through these queries and search the web
for a relevant result. First thing that
we're going to implement now is a
function to actually search the web for
relevant results. And the service we're
actually going to use today to do this
is called Exa. Uh if you haven't used it
before, highly rate it. Um
uh really enjoy using it. It's fast,
cheap.
Um, but judge for yourself like we'll
use it now and uh I think they've got a
great API and so yeah, let's build a
function to search the web with
Excel. So I'm going to copy over some
code. We'll head back to uh our codebase
and we're going to make a few new lines
here. Uh so what we're going to do is
we're going to import XA from the XAJS
package. We're going to instantiate XA
extra XA passing in our XA API key. Uh
we're going to define a type which we're
going to be using heavily later. And
then finally we are going to actually
search the web. So our search web
function takes in a query which is a
type string and then it's going to use
the excess search and contents function
uh passing in our query and then
specifying some optional config. Two
optional config we have here is one the
number of results we want. I've left
this as one just as this is a simple
demo, but you'd probably want to set
this as configurable and allow the
language model to infer what is
necessary based on maybe like how
complicated something might be. I don't
know that's something for you to
experiment with. Um and then the second
option is live crawl. Um and live crawl
is kind of as it sound allows you to or
ensures that the results that you're
getting are live. uh rather than
something that's in their cache. So you
obviously take a little bit of a hit on
performance or time for this uh result
to be executed, but you're sure that
everything that is executed is is is
live is up to
date. Now the other thing that I'm doing
here is that I'm actually mapping
through the results and only returning
the information that I feel is relevant
or necessary for completing this
process. And there are a few reasons for
doing this, but the main reason is to
reduce the number of tokens that I'm
sending to OpenAI. Um, two reasons for
that. One is that it's cheaper. Fewer
tokens just going to be cheaper. Um, but
second, and more important, I found that
the language model is so much more
effective when you trim away all of the
irrelevant information. So, um, things
like a favicon, favicon link is going to
take up a decent amount of space. not
necessary at all for the language model
to actually use these resources. So I
tend to do this a lot whenever I have
tool calls or or building out tools for
working with language models ensuring
that the information that I'm returning
or providing as part of the context is
entirely relevant to the generation or
to to the task at hand we should
say. Cool. So that's our search web
function. And now if we go back to again
our we can think of this a bit like a
checklist. The next thing that we're
going to have to do is analyze the
results um the search results for
learnings and follow-up questions. Now
this is going to be the most complicated
part of the entire workflow. And this is
also going to be the agentic part of the
workflow. And so what we're going to do
is we're going to use generate text as
we did before giving it two tools. We're
going to have a tool for searching the
web and then we're going to have a tool
for evaluating the relevance of that
tool call. And this is kind of I I say
this is the most interesting and equally
also the the agentic part um because
it's going to continue doing that flow
for as long as it takes to get a a
relevant search result. So let's see how
we can implement this. I'm going to copy
over this code and bear with me because
there's a lot there's a a decent amount
of code here. Uh but we'll walk through
all of it and see how it works. So I'm
going to also uh make sure that we've
got our imports all good. I'm going to
close off uh some of our tools and now
we're ready to go. So this function is
called search and process. It is going
to search and process. It's going to
take in our query. Again remember search
the web for a relevant result and
analyze uh search the web for map
through each query and search the web
for a relevant result. So we're taking
in that query. Uh we're going to take
we're going to create two local
variables for this for this function uh
pending search results. And if you can
think about it like this process of
searching the web and trying to figure
out if it's relevant when you search the
web you're going to add that result to
the pending search results array. And
then for evaluate, you're going to pull
out whatever the most recent uh pending
result is. Check if it's relevant. If it
is, pop it into the final search results
array. If it's not, just discard it. Um,
so that's the rough flow that we're
going to be building here. We use our
main model as the model here. Our prompt
is very complicated. Search the web for
information about our query. Uh, we give
it a system prompt. You are a
researcher. For each query, search the
web and then evaluate if the results are
relevant and will help answer the
following query. We then pass in the
query which is right here. I was looking
for it below. It's right above. Um, we
set our max steps. So, we want this
agentic loop to run up to five times.
You could set this higher and we can set
this higher for now. Um, and that will
just allow that process of finding a
relevant link to continue onwards and
onwards. I like to keep these relatively
low just to ensure that it doesn't go
off the deep end, but experiment
experiment experiment is my like main
advice for building with with these
tools. Our first tool that we have here,
I'm saying tool a lot, uh, is the search
web. This searches the web for
information about a given query. We take
in a query which is a string. uh our
string uh we then pass into the search
web function that we just created
earlier. Uh we get back some search
results that type we declared uh at the
beginning which I can show you here this
type right there. Um, and then finally,
as I was saying, we we take this local
variable, this pending search results,
and we push whatever these new uh
searched web results that we get, and we
also add those to the uh conversation
context by returning them from the tool.
And then we have the evaluate tool. And
this is to evaluate the search results.
It doesn't take in any parameters. Um
and in the execute function we are going
to pull out the latest pending result.
Uh then run it through generate object
asking it to evaluate whether the search
results are relevant and will help
answer the following query. Uh and then
we pass in with this XML syntax our
stringified pending
result. Now uh the final thing here with
this generate object rather than
specifying the schema with zod because
we just want to know whether it's
relevant or irrelevant we can actually
use generate objects enum mode to
specify just the two values that we
need. Something's either going to be
relevant or irrelevant. Uh this is super
ergonomic. You could use zod here. I
just find this very easy particularly if
you have just two values. Um and it's
also easier for the language model when
it's literally restricted to two model
to two values rather than generating a
full structured
object. Uh then if the evaluation is
relevant uh we will push the pending
result to the final result because we
know that it's now relevant. So that's
going to be a good sorts that we want to
keep. Uh we have some logs here. And
then this is interesting here. We say if
the evaluation is irrelevant, we return
the following string from this tool
call. Search results are irrelevant,
please search again with a more specific
query. So when max steps triggers the
next generation, the language model is
going to see the most recent step that
took and the last part of that most
recent step i.e. the tool result was
please search again with a more specific
query. So we have this system that is
repeating um but with feedback based on
what's going on. The last thing to
mention here is the fact that I did not
use the parameters here to parse out the
search result. And uh there's a very uh
specific reason for doing that. Search
result can be super long, right? This
could be a whole entire crawled web page
that could be I don't know 10,000
tokens. And we don't want the model to
have to actually parse that out. It's
literally generating the text that
already exists in the context above.
One, costs money. Two, it takes a long
time. Three, it's probably errorprone
because it's literally just writing out
stuff that's above. It's not referencing
it. And that's why I like to do this um
these local variables within this
function faster, cheaper, more accurate,
and so on. So this is the search and
process function and we can add it to
our main function and see how it works.
So we're going to
console.log our search results and see
see what we got. So we'll clear this
out, run the function
again. Searching the web for
requirements to become a D1 shotput
athlete.
Found throws university benchmark lifts
to throw 50 ft from school shotput.
Evaluation completed. It's
irrelevant. So it found a new
one. Considered it irrelevant.
found another one men's track recruiting
standards and considered that irrelevant
or considered that relevant sorry and
then it returned a bunch of oh boy we
returned the whole result. So this is
like the whole scraped uh web page in
here. So we can see very cool it is
working great. So let's move on to the
next step. And what is the next step? Uh
the next step is to analyze the results
for learnings and follow-up questions.
So to do this, we're going to again
create a new function. This new function
is going to be called generate
learnings. It's going to take in a query
which is a string and then uh the search
result itself. So this is like the the
web page in the scripted content. We're
then going to use uh surprise surprise
my favorite function generate object
using our main model again and providing
a prompt here. This time the user is
researching query. the following search
results were deemed relevant. Generate a
learning and a follow-up question from
the following search result. We use
those XML tags again to nest in our
search result that is stringified. And
then finally, we specify as our schema
we want uh a a string which is the
learning itself, the insight we could
probably call it. and then uh any
follow-up questions which are an array
of strings and we return that object
which is this type safe uh structured
output. Cool. So we can incorporate that
into our main function again. Let's
replace all of that. And we can see now
that we are we have our prompt, we have
our queries. We we for each query we're
going to search the web search and
process. So we're searching and making
sure that the the result is relevant.
And then for each of the results that
are returned, we're then going to pass
it to our generate learnings function,
passing in that original query and then
the um the search result. So we could
again test to see how things are
looking. Run the
script. Searching the web for
requirements to become a D1 shop.
athlete. Let's see how many times uh I
have said that in um in this
video. So, it's deemed that this is
irrelevant, but the next link that it
finds is relevant. So, it's now
processing this search result and then
we're going to get a learning. So, what
do we have here? To become a D1 shop at
athlete, high school athletes typically
need to have four years of varsity
experience, achieve highstate finishes
or be state champions, and participate
in national events like USATF National
Junior Olympic Outdoor Track and Field
Championships. They should also aim for
shot put distance of around I think
that's 60 feet um for tier one recruits.
Um and then we've got some follow-up
questions. What are the specific
training regimens for shot put athletes?
How do division one recruiting standards
differ from division two and three? Some
like really interesting threads to to go
down. So, what we're going to have to do
naturally now is introduce recursion to
this whole process. Meaning now that we
have our learnings, we effectively want
to take the follow-up questions, create
a new query, and call the entire process
again until uh effectively we we are
happy with the the depth of information
that we've gathered. So there are going
to be a few things that we need to do.
One, we need to probably create a new
function that can handle this recursion
rather than doing it all in the main
function.
two, we're going to have to we're not
going to be able to track all of our uh
accumulated research in in the local
function anymore. We're going to have to
create some state or a variable outside
in in the global state to be able to
track this as we go through. And then
we're probably going to need some types
as well just to help make this all a bit
easier. So, let's add those. Now, first
things first, we're going to create a
new function uh called uh deep research
to um to actually that will be able to
handle our recursion. So all we've done
here is taken our previous logic that
was within the main function and put it
into a new function called deep
research. Um so as you can see we we're
generating search queries, we are then
searching and process then we're
generating learning. So, same as before.
And then in our main function, this time
we define our prompt and then we um call
that deep research function. So, what
we're going to have to do now is
actually call this function recursively.
But first things first, we're going to
need to create
uh a place to store our accumulated
research
state. So, I'm going to copy in some
code here. Uh we're defining two types.
Uh a learning type which we've seen
before. This was the the the learning
the insight from the research and then
follow-up questions. Um and then
research. This is the core accumulated
research object um or store um and we
store in like our original query, the
queries that have been performed um or
the queries the active queries right now
the search results and accumulation of
all of them uh learnings all the
insights and then completed queries. And
at the very end, as this develops, we're
going to pass all of that state, that
store of information to one large model
that can synthesize all of that and
generate our report. But first, we need
to update our deep research function to
actually update the store as it's
iterating through these levels of
recursion. So, let's head to our deep
research function. I'm going to copy all
of this and we'll look at what we've
updated here. So the first thing that
we've done um is we we've changed the
name of one uh parameter from query to
prompt just so you know uh we've also
updated our depth and breadth uh
numbers. So depth remember are the
levels deep that we go into the the the
the strands that will or the levels of
the strands that will go down and then
breadth are those like individual forks
how many of them will go down at each
level. So we first check to see if a
query is undefined. That will be on the
first time we're ever running this. Um
and if it is, we'll set it to the the
prompt. We then like last time we
generate the search queries. This time
we update our queries to be that that uh
whatever is returned from the search
queries. Um and that's a theme as we go
through here. We're going to update our
accumulated research to take in our our
search results, our learnings, and our
completed queries. And now that we have
this all out of the way, we can actually
call deep research recursively. Um, and
at the same time, we're going to
decrement the depth and breadth so that
we can eventually get to a resolution.
Uh, so this doesn't run forever and we
don't run out of all of our API credits
and leave the user waiting for for way
too long. So, let's add that final
recursion. I'm going to replace the
entire function again um just so I don't
make any mistakes here. We've added two
things here. First, we've said uh if the
depth is is zero, uh just return
effectively like recursion is done at
this point uh return the accumulated
research. Um and now for the new stuff
where before we had the comments saying
perform the deep research now instead we
create a new query saying the overall
research goal is this. These are the
previous search queries that have been
performed. Here are some follow-up
questions. Um and then we pass that back
and call the entire function again with
that new prompt. uh again decrementing
the depth and the breadth at a more
exponential
rate. So I think that's a good as good a
time as any to to run the function again
and and kind of see what's happening. We
should see it now going into various
levels of depth. Again I'm saying
requirements to become a D1 shotput
athlete. So this uh source is deemed
irrelevant. It keeps liking to use that
one. Instead, the track recruiting
standards is deemed relevant. We're now
processing the search result. We're
going to be generating some
learnings. We're now searching the web
for what physical and technical skills
are essential for a D1 shot athlete. So,
we're going a level of depth
here. We found uh some some relevant
Now we're searching again training and
skills needed for D1 shotput
athletes and so on and so forth. So we
can see that it is indeed working.
One thing though that we haven't done
yet is that we haven't incorporated into
and funny enough we didn't see this in
this example but the way that our logic
works right now when the model is trying
to decide whether a link is relevant it
doesn't have context as to the links
that have already been used in other
steps and naturally we've been talking
about context length price speed we
don't we we surely do not want to
provide the same source course twice,
particularly if it's taking up 10 20,000
tokens in length. So what we're going to
do is we're going to go to our search
and process function. We're going to
head into our evaluate tool and in this
evaluate tool, we're also going to pass
in previously used search results. And
if the search result exists in that
previously used search results, we're
going to say that's an irrelevant source
and and try again.
So I'm going to copy the entire
function, replace the entire function
here. Um, this time we're taking in a
new parameter here, accumulated sources.
Um, and if we scroll down, we should see
our updated prompt. We say if the page
already exists in the existing results,
mark it as irrelevant. And we can see
we're passing it in in XML tags existing
results and stringifying through passing
just the URL because also we don't need
all the content from the page here. We
literally just need the URL. We have one
error here and that's because we added a
new argument but we haven't passed it in
here. So I'm going to just pass that in
here. Uh this will be the accumulated
research dot um I think this is the
search results. Yeah, search results.
Perfect. Uh, so if we were to to run
this again, what we would see, we didn't
see it in the previous example before,
but if it reused a source or if Exa
returned a source that it had already
used in a previous step, that would now
be marked as irrelevant and that agentic
process would continue on in a loop. The
last thing that we're going to want to
do, which I actually don't have in in
this process, is that now that we have
all this accumulated research, we want
to give it to a big model, I I prefer a
reasoning model in this case to
synthesize all of this information and
put it into a report that we can consume
to hopefully solve our query. So, let's
create a new function. This function is
going to be called a very creative name
as per usual uh generate report. It's
going to take in that accumulated
research which is typed as such. Um and
then we're going to call generate texts.
This time we're using 03 mini rather
than our main model. Uh again play
around with this clone this and and see
which models uh you like best for this
kind of thing. I found 03 mini very good
at this. And then our prompt here, we're
saying generate a report based on the
following research data. We've got two
new lines and then we stringify the
report returning the final generated
text. So let's actually refactor our
main function very quickly to use this
new
uh this new function. So what we're
doing here uh we've just inlined our
prompt. So we say uh what do you need to
to be a D1 shop athlete? We log out some
status updates and then we pass that
research into the generate report
function await it and get out a report
which will finally write to the file
system to a markdown file. So I'm going
to import fs from fs and then we're
ready to go.
So let's see let's see what this does.
Great. So, after about a minute, we've
got our report. Below is an integrated
report summarizing the research findings
on what it takes to become a division
one shotput athlete along with a with
related insights on technique, training,
and common beginner pitfalls. So, okay,
we've got our our entire report here.
Um, and to be honest, given all of the
information that we gave it, it's it's
pretty it's pretty great. But one thing
that we'll note here is that we didn't
give the model any guidance on what
exactly we wanted this report to look
like. And so the model had to infer. Um,
and when when you're working with
language models, in order to get the
best response, you want to leave as
little up to the model to infer as
possible. So, one thing, I want this to
be in a markdown format. Two, I'd like
it to to form a bit more of a structure
um that I want to specify. And so, what
we're going to do here is we're going to
head back to our uh generate research
function. And we're going to do two
things. We're going to actually just one
thing, sorry. We're going to create a
system prompt. We're going to tell it
give it a persona. You are an expert
researcher. We're going to give it
today's date. We're going to tell it to
follow these instructions exactly. Um,
and a few key things in here. We're
going to say use markdown
formatting. You may use high levels of
speculation or prediction. Just flag it.
Um, and and in general, we just give it
these these uh guidelines that are very
research uh analyst oriented. So, I'm
going to run this entire thing again,
and we're going to see the difference in
the output.
And here it is. We have our new report.
So, let's jump into it. And what can we
notice right off the bat? We're using
markdown, which is awesome. Much more
structured. Uh we can see that we've got
date and line kind of helpful to have.
Um but like the the level of quality of
this kind of report even just with this
basic workflow really astounds me. So
you can see to be considered like right
at the top level to be considered a
division one shot pro prospect athletes
are expected to demonstrate a high level
of competitive success varsity
experience um typically four years of
varsity participation competitive
exposure. Uh we have performance
benchmarks a benchmark throw of 55 ft.
elite or top tier recruits tend to have
distances around 60 feet and 18 inches.
Like this is uh and the difference
between men's and women. It it is so so
so cool how uh we were able to build
this in just 218 lines of code. Um so
yeah this is this is it. This is a
session. I hope you enjoyed this. If you
have any questions, you can reach me on
um X the everything platform at niko
albanese10. Uh feel free to send me a
DM. Uh if you have any questions on
building with the SDK, head to
SDK.purcell.ai, check out our docs. We
got some awesome uh guides in the
cookbook as well. Um and yeah, I hope
you enjoyed this. I want to thank Swix
for asking me to to do this uh session
and I really hope you enjoyed it and
hope to see you at the next one. Take
care.